[Music]
today's question comes from caleb in
scotland did i do that right that was a
pretty rough accent but continue it
wasn't great
it's fine
today's question comes from caleb
william wallace in scotland better says
my friends have gotten caught up in the
bitcoin market craze and are making a
lot of money trading
i know your company says it's not a
secure investment but i have to admit
i'm intrigued by the money they're
making
is it a good idea to put some of my
emergency fund in bitcoin and see how
fast i can grow my savings george you
are a bitcoin expert oh my gosh john
okay so we did an episode on on the fine
print all about bitcoin we called it is
bitcoin your ticket to wealth could
bitcoin be your ticket 12. and what made
me laugh at the end there was to see how
fast i can grow my savings and in my
head i thought you mean to see how fast
you can lose your savings
the that's the question i want you to
ask it's a risk problem john i know
you're you're big on this risk analysis
and what we found with bitcoin is that
we're not against bitcoin i'm not mad at
you if you want to put some money in
bitcoin but this is not your 15
retirement we're not banking on this
money to live off of now if you want to
do some fun money if you're debt-free
you're already investing you've got your
life taken care of you want to put some
fun money into bitcoin that's fine have
some fun with it but treat it like
entertainment because right now that's
what it is and so no it's not a good
idea to put your emergency fund in
bitcoin because guess what when there's
an emergency you're gonna need that
money and it needs to be liquid you need
to be able to pull that out of the
account and know it's going to be there
and with the drop of a dime or elon musk
saying something on saturday night live
your emergency fund could vanish
evaporates that frightens me so don't do
that man put it put your emergency fund
in a money market account and a
high-yield savings account and keep it
there part for safety this is not where
you want to play with investing and for
those of you who want to use bitcoin as
a hedge
the dollar's all going down so we're
going to have
please don't please please
do just a rudimentary risk assessment on
how
how currency works don't do that don't
do that love yourself more than that
right
that's all i'm going to say that's it
that's it caleb thanks for the question
all the way across many ponds to
scotland yeah that's fun and we can't i
wish i could have freedom either i wish
you would have called in and i could
have heard that amazing scottish accent